that is a something which I regret
deeply and that is principally no no
explanation and we should have done that
honestly during the last nine years and
I had I should have done that when I
took over in November 2014 that was my
biggest mistake that I was not trying to
get into contact with the family I did
that today I said yesterday I do want to
do the right things I did the right
things and I'm grateful that the family
gave me the chance to meet them
personally today and how did the meeting
go have the family accepted your apology
the meeting was very intense and I
really just wanted to listen to them
what their story is and I wanted to hear
it from them and it was for me
heartbreaking and I apologized I
apologized for what I did not write in
the last days and I apologized what
mistakes thomas cook in the last nine
years state and i finally came with the
family to an agreement that they can
move on with their lives which they
deserve right now obviously you're
making certain financial payments to
them which they in turn a passing on to
charity are you able to disclose
precisely how much money you've given
the family
we agreed that the family is a informing
about the outcome of the meeting because
I want by all means avoid that it could
come across that I used that now as
somehow a PR story for thomas cook i
said i want to stop to talk about the
family i want to talk with the family
this i achieved today and I'm grateful
for that right now it's emerged
separately this evening that a man who
was convicted over the negligent
manslaughter of these two children has
ended up working back at a hotel that is
used by Thomas Cook how on earth is I
have been allowed to happen when I got
that news yesterday evening I almost got
sick and this is absolutely not
acceptable under I took immediate action
we were getting into contact with the
management of the group we were asking
miss immediate effect that this hotel
director is going to be fired and that
has been done yesterday night still we
did as well or we send our head of risk
and audit immediate immediately on a
plane down to Crete to make health and
safety audit starting this morning and
as a third action we were really
investigating there are those three
people from the hotel who were convicted
in in 2010 where are they working and we
realized that also an electrician in
Corfu is still working in this hotel in
Corfu where the tragedy happened and we
immediately stopped be sent from Holland
because the hotel has been totally
refurbished we sent from Holland still
guests into this hotel we immediately
stopped that because the hotel was
giving not an acceptable explanation to
us that they are not able legally to
fail this this employee and we are not
accepting that right are you in a
position that we will you just cut off
hotels in this position where they
found to be doing things like this and
how can customers be absolutely certain
that their health and safety is being
treated in a paramount manner by thomas
cook my absolute focus and that phone
from Thomas Cook is that we are at the
forefront of Health and Safety and what
I decided as well today is that we are
engaging independent expert who is a
health and safety expert who makes a
thorough investigation on our health and
safety processes throughout and
reporting directly to me to really get
all the process is hundred percent right
that we are on top of Health and Safety
now you mentioned just now that not
speaking to the family and apologizing
to the family earlier had been your
biggest mistake since you took over as
chief executive is that resigning issue
no no I do not I will not resign because
I did say I am going to do the right
things I take the right things today and
I want to get it right so there is
nothing on my agenda that has something
to do with designing I want to get
Thomas Cook really great and I'm
committed to do this CEO job here at
Thomas Cook the best i can do you think
you've still got the confidence of your
shareholders though given that this has
been handled so badly I'm convinced that
I still got the confidence of the
shareholders I'm totally convinced of
that because I decided at the beginning
or during the weekend that I'm going to
stop talking about the family I wanted
to talk with the family and I wanted and
I by doing that I stand the pressure of
the media who were expecting principally
that I still to talk with them about the
whole tragedy and I
just wanted to stop I wanted to deliver
on my promise that I want to do it right
and I did it right and I did the right
thing and I got the chance from the
family that I could meet them today
right now there's been a online boycott
building over the last week or so ever
since the inquest in fact are you seeing
much evidence of customers canceling
bookings yet or choosing to book with
some of your competitors that was
absolutely not my focus now during the
last days we don't see booking patent
state today we didn't see a real an
impact on on bookings but this was not
my focus during the last days my focus
was really that I can meet the family
and that I can give them a new a new
base to start from here and do to move
on from here right and did the fact when
you met the family did they know that
this man who had been convicted of
negligent manslaughter was back working
at a Thomas Cook hotel did they know
that I don't know whether they did know
it but I told them about this fact
because I really I want to be as open
with the family as you are as i am and
i'm an open person so i really i wanted
to do due to tell them that that i have
here a problem and that i resolved it
that way that must have been incredibly
distressing moment for the family how
did they react to that news
we agreed that about the content of
these discussions we are not going to
talk in public right right but that I
mean that must have just been an
absolute dreadful moment for them
learning that a man who was convicted of
the manslaughter of their children is
back working at a hotel operated by
thomas cook I mean that's unbelievable
this manager was employed in April it
I'm really I'm really got almost sick
that it was not us who detected that
first instance I'm sure that we would
have detected that but we didn't detect
that within a reasonable six month
period and this is exactly where I said
we need now at third part the expert an
expert who is totally independent on
health and safety who can really make a
thorough investigation to tell me and
the organization where we still have to
improve but we improved since 2006 be
improved a lot we we are not making the
cell health and safety audits on our own
with our own colleagues we have external
specialists who are doing that which who
are doing nothing else than health and
safety audits but this guy has been back
in the hotel for something like six
months I think you just said I'm it's
astonishing that no one's picked pick
that up is anyone from you know he
started no he he started he started in
April he started in april this year that
means is about four to six weeks ago if
I said months that was clearly a mistake
in my language then okay but should not
someone from your internal audit or risk
department who have picked up on that I
mean surely someone's someone's head
should roll for this shouldn't it the
immediately took action we immediately
sent the head of has safety and audit on
spot and we immediately took them the
right decisions to say okay now we have
really to see
those are the two are and we have found
one and we took as well they action
right do you think the Thomas Cook
Brandis is capable of withstanding this
I mean it's been a torrid year for you
in other respects I'm you a parachuted
into the job at relatively short notice
last November consumers could withstand
all of this can it take much more of
this I Thomas Cook is a wonderful
company Thomas go kisser is a extremely
strong brand Thomas Cook has 22,000
really engaged employees and it has 22
million guests who are going on holidays
with thomas cook in one year and the
absolute majority is really enjoying
making a holiday with us and we are
really caring about the customer with
our fourth without 5000 to 6000 reps we
have in the destinations during the
summer season who are doing nothing else
than caring about our customers and we
proved many many times in the past when
we had crisis that we do absolutely the
right thing that we care about our
customers and if I may give an example
when in Tunisia the Raven spring broke
out we were the first to operator who
decided to evacuate all our guests out
of Tunisia we were the one who still had
the time to really fly them out the same
day and be averted one who had all at
home the earliest we could and the
fastest so we are really caring about
about the customer and as well about
health and safety okay now this these
deaths occurred under your predecessor
but one Manny Fontana navarre who
appeared at the inquest as the company
explored any way of clawing back
payments or bonuses that were made to
mr. Fontana and of our during his time
in office now
and I take it it goes without saying I
imagine that you won't be accepting any
bonus in respective of this year looked
at the may salaries here not the my
salary's here not on discussion and this
is a man that the board decides okay
Peter fankhauser from thomas cook group
we appreciate you joining us this
evening they good to speak to you and
thank you for taking the time